[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue au
sommaire de cette émission la question
des migrants de leur recensement dans
les centres d'hébergement et des
critiques qui se multiplient y compris
au sein de en marche
nous parlerons aussi d'économie avec ses
belles perspectives de croissance
annoncées de bons chiffres dans le btp
dans l'immobilier mais cette bouffée
d'oxygène comment l'exploiter au mieux
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
seront qu'il l'optimiser nous verrons
cela on s'arrêtera aussi sur l'autriche
l'autriche où les conservateurs ont fait
alliance avec l'extrême droite
quel visage a vraiment ce nouveau
gouvernement faut-il en avoir peur au
contraire faut-il le banaliser vous avez
certainement un point de vue là dessus
et enfin nous feront un détour par les
réseaux sociaux on y trouve le pire
comme le meilleur
les français s'en méfient en tout cas
comme source d'information top trop
d'impôts trop d'intox sur le web
au point que certains prédisent la mort
de facebook nous allons dans un instant
parler de tous ces sujets mais avant les
présentations elles seront rapides car
vous êtes tous des habitués autour de la
table bonjour adélaïde zulfikarpasic
vous êtes directrice de bva opinion et
vous nous fait le plaisir d'intervenir
régulièrement dans point de vue mais
resservez à côté de vous jean marc four
bonjour jean marc canon rejoint 12 est
directeur de la rédaction de france
inter et vous êtes l'auteur de deux la
mécanique médiatique qui est paru chez
lemieux en 2016 en face de vous un
tandem figaro bonjour vincent très
moléculaires dont je croyais rédacteur
en chef des pages débats opinion du
figaro est l'auteur de conversation
française c'est paru aux éditions du
cerf l'année dernière et avec à côté de
vous marc landré bonjour marc bonjour
une heure en chef au service économie du
figaro
eh bien merci à thé auteurs d'orient et
auteur de sans doute beaucoup de papier
en tout cas qui nous régale
régulièrement
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre on va
commencer par les cette question des
migrants ce sera le dossier de la
rentrée de janvier la politique
migratoire
le gouvernement est déjà sous le feu des
critiques à gauche parmi les
associations la contestation monte et
même au sein en marche
quelques voix discordantes commencent à
se faire entendre alors le principe des
deux jambes cher à emmanuel
kron humanité et fermeté
s'appliquera-t-il en 2018 jusqu'où ira
le projet de loi sur l'immigration la
majorité peut-elle se fragmenter sur
cette question on va en parler mais
d'abord on regarde la ministre des
affaires européennes nathalie loiseau
elle affiche son réalisme un réalisme
qui sera salué ensuite par manuel valls
l'ancien premier ministre on les regarde
tous les deux aujourd'hui ce dès 2010
est à peu près 95 1097 mille demandes
d'asile c'est considérable on est face à
une crise migratoire depuis 2015
on n'est pas dans une situation où on
peut se dire on continue comme avant on
ne change rien et ça marche la réalité
c'est que ça ne marche pas cette
circulaire ne me choque pas elle est
destinée à davantage d'efficacité de ce
soit une question de sentiment d'une
question ce qui d link à ces deux
principes le droit d'asile la générosité
mais aussi d'efficacité et vous savez
quand on gouverne
j'en sais quelque chose on est confronté
à ce principe de réalité il faut pas
perdre les principes et les valeurs
mais il faut être efficace c'est le
prochain écueil pour le gouvernement
cette question de l'immigration
je ne suis pas sûr je pense que
le calcul de emmanuel macron est assez
bon en fait d'abord je pense qu'il va à
nouveau affirmé sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres que vous savez de tony blair
c'est prévisible britanniques visés à 19
avril heureuse que ce qui veut dire je
n'ai pas de marche arrière
je pense que les manuels wagon est assez
dense et logique l'as des as de poser
quelque chose à dire je n'ai pas de
marche arrière je vais de l'avant
première premier premier point et
deuxième point je pense que à nouveau là
il s'efforce de priver toute la droite
de tout l'espace politique donc il le
fait aussi sur ce sujet là et je pense
que c'est assez adroit parce que cela
fait écho à des préoccupations des
français sur le sujet n'est d'accord
d'un centre et volley s'est associé à la
droite et est ce que c'est ce que ce qui
préside et politiques politiciens ou
c'est une vue politique ça j'en sais
rien en tout cas il ya eu chez makro un
revirement c'est à dire que pendant sa
campagne il faisait d'angela merkel un
modèle et notamment de l'accueil des
réfugiés par merkel un modèle depuis en
gala merkel a perdu les élections et
dans une situation très compliquée toute
l'europe de l'est a été traumatisée par
cette crise des migrants j'ai retrouvé
dans l'excellent journal le figaro
l'interview que isabelle lasserre avait
fait de yann kraft steph qui est un
intellectuel très influent en europe de
l'est qui disait la crise des migrants
c'est le 11 septembre de l'union
européenne et je pense que macro à
mesurer ça et peut-être que ce qui lui
remonte du ministère de l'intérieur et
de gérard collomb et que les difficultés
sont telles qu'il faut prendre des
décisions fermes
alors après il se trouve que ces
décisions lui permettent politiquement
de boucher l'espace de laurent wauquiez
et d'achever une métamorphose quand même
assez sidérante qui est qu'on a eu un
candidat me lie à un mini socialiste un
candidat de centre gauche a président de
centre-droit qui va peut-être finir
comme un président de droite tout court
il allait à delayed vincent très molle
et le souligner les remontées de
l'opinion est ce que c'est ça qui
effectivement peut motiver le
gouvernement la majorité sans pour une
politique de fermer deux favorables une
politique de fermeté mais en même temps
il ya une minorité active qui est très
agissante alors comment naviguer entre
les deux c'est un sujet effectivement
qui est sensible mais je pense quand
même je rejoins l'analyse qui a été
faite par jean marc four que emmanuel
macron a raison d'y aller parce que
alors il ya le côté tactique
politicienne et effectivement on sait
que sympathisant
elle est en particulier sont très
sensibles à ce sujet il en fait même une
de leur priorité numéro un
mais même quand on élargit le la focale
et qu'on regarde l'ensemble des français
c'est un sujet sur lesquels les français
ont des attentes un peu force alors
c'est un peu un sujet tabou on soit trop
s'exprimer mais par exemple je peux vous
dire que plus d'un français sur deux
estime qu'en france il ya trop
d'immigrés aujourd'hui et seulement 14 %
d'entre eux pensent que l'immigration a
un impact positif par rapport à ce qu
elle ce qu'elle offre au pays donc je
pense que les attentes assez forte des
français
et s'il arrive à jouer cette espèce de
quitte j'aurais de gens montrent un
humanisme et fermeté ça peut être plutôt
payant pour lui plein gouvernement non
je vous rappelle la question sur
laquelle vous pouvez vous prononcez la
question ces migrants le gouvernement
va-t-il reculer marc landré comme le
souligne adélaïde il ya la fois cette
question du poids que peut représenter
pour l'opinion le les l'immigration en
france on a longtemps parlé du poids
économique
après on a basculé plus tôt aujourd'hui
sur le poids en matière plus de
culture le poids économique ça reste une
constante dans les préoccupations des
français et dans le ski peut gouverner
une apolitique effectivement de se dire
il faut faire attention faut faire
attention parce que avoir cent mille
deux mille demandes d'asile c'est pas la
même chose en france que d'en avoir dix
mille c'est un coût économique pour
l'état qui est obligée de prendre en
charge les personnes qui sont en attente
de soi de régularisation ou de réponse
mais surtout c'est un véritable problème
pour les gens dans le sens où on a une
incapacité actuellement de les intégrer
on parlait de fleurs de l'allemagne en
allemagne ils ont reçu pendant la grande
vague 1 million de deux migrants qu'ils
ont été plutôt en capacité d'intégrer
économiquement et c'est un bienfait pour
une économie qui perd des actifs de
l'autre côté du rhin ce n'est pas le cas
chez nous on a une démographie qui est
plutôt positive et donc c'est compliqué
de les intégrer surtout dans une
économie où il ya déjà beaucoup de
chômage
la problématique des migrants à titre
personnel je pense qu' elle ne se
poserait pas si on était capable de les
intégrer économiquement et qu'on avait
une place à leurs données dans
l'économie c'est difficile aujourd'hui
parce qu'on a plus de 3 millions de
chômeurs et que on a d un système
administratif qui a du mal à se
positionner par rapport à eux
et au final si on n'est ce pas ce
problème d'intégration n'aurait pas de
m2 coûte
ce qui est fascinant dans cette histoire
et dans tout le ce début de quinquennat
c'est que ça fait encore un sujet sur
lequel il y avait des tensions énormes
c'était vraiment des sujets inflammable
et il ya une espèce de consensus qui se
fait dans l'opinion il ya eu çà sur
l'économie avec la loi travail vous
finalement l'opposition était très très
mesuré il ya eu çà sur l'école ou quand
même jean michel blanquer r&d roubles un
programme pour le moment sans aucune
difficulté
et ce sur ce sujet extrêmement sensible
on al'impression alors peut-être que on
verra des choses que vous auquel on ne
s'attend pas à un retour de flamme et on
a mal on a l'impression qu'il ya un
consensus dans l'opinion pour dire on
peut plus accueillir tout le monde c'est
pas possible c'est trop lourd et je ne
crois pas que les gens soient fermés et
ne voit pas la misère et la détresse de
ceux qui veulent rejoindre le continent
européen
mais ils ont compris que cette
crise comment exiger une politique de
fermeté et réfléchi parce que macron va
on l'a vu dans son émission dimanche par
du sahel quand même et a vu le continuum
qui existe entre le la crise migrants et
les demandeurs d'asile et pas je donne
juste le résultat provisoire de notre
question sur twitter donc pour le moment
vous êtes 59 % à estimer que le
gouvernement ne va pas reculer
donc sur le consensus jean-marc mais il
n'y a pas de conscience surtout je pense
terre il ya une relatif consensus je
pense je le fait qu'effectivement il
faut être sans doute assez stricte à
l'entrée c'est à dire sur le contrôle
aux frontières en sachant qu'on a tout
toute cette question de savoir si
l'europe est capable de le faire au delà
des frontières françaises
la controverse d'aujourd'hui portent sur
un autre sujet en réalité ça vous
allemand - consensus c'est à dire que
une fois que ces immigrés ces réfugiés
sont sur le sol français
quel comportement adopter nous vis-à-vis
d'eux en sachant que l'expérience montre
qu'on le veuille ou non que
les reconduites sont inefficaces c'est à
dire que d'abord il y en a peu en
proportion et d'autre part il ya une
grande convention une fois qu'ils sont
reconduits qui reviennent
ne serait ce que parce que pour nombre
d'entre eux ils ont mis en fait ils sont
entrés déjà par un autre pays de l'union
européenne dans lequel ils ont déjà des
formes de papier si vous voulez donc ils
vont venir donc lalla ounissa -
consensus je pense et c'est là qu'est la
controverse aujourd'hui avec notamment
les associations secours populaire
emmaüs et c'est quand même un grand
nombre d'associations qui se sont élevés
contre cette circulaire
c'est sur le fait de savoir comment se
comporte vis à vis d'eux une fois qu'ils
sont sur notre sol c'est la liste ont
effectivement des centres d'hébergement
d'urgence qu'il faut alors et là il ya
peut-être un début de recul parce que là
par rapport à la circulaire publiée par
gérard collomb il ya déjà un nom va pas
mettre de la police on va envoyer des
fonctionnaires mais pas tout à fait donc
est ce que oui là là dessus on sent un
petit recul ou c'est encore la matière
la grogne la grogne associations mais
quand vous voyez et xavier emmanuelli
qui est le patron du samu social qui
explique qu' on n'accueille pas
dignement dans des conditions humaines
des gens qui ont traversé la moitié de
l'afrique et la méditerranée pour venir
chez nous que ce soit à titre provisoire
ou définitif c'est un effectif je pense
que le gouvernement ne peut pas ne pas
entendre ce type d'appels de personnes
qui est totalement dépolitisé qui ne
veut que le bien de son prochain et qui
a une ride certaine résonance dans une
partie de la population donc eux savent
allier sur politiciens saint soumises
oui il a raison c'est comme ça c'est
peut-être l'année bien danger et puis
avec un veuf et qu'on réponde façon il
faut voir c'est comme sur l'économie il
faut aider faut 18 mois et on verra s'il
ya des reconduites à la frontière si on
n'a pas si c'est des gesticulations
c'est de la politique politicienne ou
pas mais il ya quand même un certain
nombre de propos du président de la
république notamment ceux qu'il a tenus
aux restos du coeur devant cette femme
marocaine ou en afrique qui sont des
signaux pour les immigrants potentiels
disant nous ne pouvons pas vous
accueillir et ça c'est quand j'arrête
franchement je n'en sais rien mais en
tout cas c'est nouveau ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est par exemple les
dissuader voilà je ne sais pas si c'est
les déçus et on se sait pas si c'est
perrault les pertes performative mais
cette parole ça n'existait pas on doit
on
c'est pas à une personne existe de voir
l'élision elle n'existait pas mais
l'afrique
françoise nous dit c'est triste mais il
faut arrêter de prendre des migrants
c'est onéreux et on oublie les plus
démunis chez nous c'est souvent
effectivement une remarque qui revient à
délais
ce qu'il ya c'est inné c'est qu'on voit
que alors même qu'ils ont été critiquées
en début de quinquennat pour l'heure
leur capacité à suivre les gouvernements
talent sans s'exprimer on voit que des
députés de la république en marche
eux-mêmes interpellent le gouvernement
et ça c'est nouveau
et effectivement ça nous rappelle aussi
que la république en marche les
électeurs au départ et y compris les
acteurs de manioc de macron ils viennent
principalement des rangs de la gauche et
donc effectivement ça peut
certaines de ces mesures peuvent heurter
en termes de valeur effectivement sur
l'aspect comment est-ce qu'on traite les
migrants une fois qu'ils sont sur notre
sol sa pureté une partie des électorats
initial emmanuel macron qu'on voit en
tout cas qu'on a un sujet qui peut être
inflammable en début d'année ça va être
comme un peu le sujet même l'électorat
je dirais de centre-droit
démocrate-chrétien d'achat semble de
valeurs d'accueil de charité de voyez ce
que je veux dire assez c'est pour ça que
le sujet est un peu plus complexe que la
seule france est soumise pour reprendre
euh oui par exemple on l'a vu ce
week-end avec cette cordée solidaire
dans les wings alpes alors ça réunissait
des gens très divers un des guides de
haute montagne les habitants puissent
après que cette fameuse circulaire peut
être contre productive à c'est ce que
disent aussi les associations c'est à
dire que en fait elle est si on commence
à dire on va envoyer des fonctionnaires
contrôlé dans les centre pour sans abri
le fait que n'y résident pas des
réfugiés en situation irrégulière on
peut conduire lesdites personnes en fait
éviter d'aller dans ces centres est donc
se retrouver encore davantage en
situation
complètement démuni de précarité dans la
rue et on sera pas plus avancés on va
juste vous voulez on déplace un problème
et on peut provoquer la mort déjà enfin
je les accepte aussi simple que ça
passera le jour où il y aura des morts
des migrants morts dans la rue parce
qu'il veut quand il aura les grands
froids qui vont arriver
est ce que est ce que ça se retournera
pas contre l'exécutif parce qu'ils l'ont
renvoyé et des forces de police dans les
récentes pour les contrôler ils
faillirent ccc un des merdes a comme
problème c'est très compliquée et
politiquement effectivement très
explosif et sensible peut-être donc vous
l'analysez comme effectivement un
obstacle à surmonter pour le
gouvernement dans les prochains mois oui
on sait pas c'est plus que plus que le
premier trimestre le trimestre pour un
ca de la loi travail du budget je pense
que la tension avait même été détournés
sur d'autres problèmes au début du
quinquennat
maintenant en plus parce qu'il fait
froid virilio si une musique ne dit que
j'irais consumériste et les gens dorment
dans la rue mangeant la rue on les voit
plus que quand il fait beau
donc ça je pense qu'il ya aussi une
première un problème de saison et que
les problèmes sont détournés d'autres
choses on ne parle plus belle ou beau
travail on parle pas encore d autres
problèmes économiques qui vont arriver
aujourd'hui c'est en bas de chez lou
grant enjeux politiques des années à
venir et donc jean christophe rufin 2010
est là dans l'interview qu'il nous a
donnée au figaro magazine il disait le
le grand sujet du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron c'est ça et donc c'est évidemment
très compliqué ça exige des décisions
géopolitique c'est existe des décisions
sécuritaires décision humanitaire mais
il est obligé de s'en emparer
et moi je pense qu'il a raison de
restaurer l'idée que le droit d'asile
pour qu'il existe ne peut pas être
ouvert à tous parce que sinon ça veut
dire que tout le monde est réfugié au
même titre quelqu'un qui risque sa vie
parce que il a une certaine religion
parce qu'il a eu des positions
politiques une orientation ce qui suit
sexuelle c'est pas la même chose que
quelqu'un qui voudrait vivre dans un
pays en tant que ces discours de la
france veut dire ses débuts de discours
de la france depuis rocard que
l'académie allait pas autre chose
oui mais vu qu'on pouvait pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde la distinction
réfugiés qu'on a faim migrants
économiques et réfugiés politiques est
ce qu'elle est toujours tout à fait
pertinente parce que ça leur semble mais
elle existe elle existe elle est parfois
dream qui dit ça il n'y allait pas
appliquée parce qu'on s'aide soit aux
associations qui veulent
rire tout le monde soit au pendant
averses qui vous aident les gens qui
vous accueillent personne dit il ya des
règles et si on essayait au moins
d'appliquer ces règles c'est à dire
pourquoi est ce que vous êtes en danger
de mort pour ce que vous êtes dans votre
pays
et si vous n'êtes pas en danger de mort
et qu'on ne peut pas vous accueillir
parce qu'on n'a pas de métier on peut
pas vous intégrez vous ne pouvez pas
rentrer alors c'est facile à dire mais
si déjà cette règle basique est
installée dans les esprits et dans
l'administration peut-être pourra-t-on
semblait penser que c'est à dire c'est
rien ça en deux cas de figure moi par
exemple j'ai une joyeuse de la rédaction
de france inter qui rentrent du niger
qui est allé passer près de trois
semaines là-bas sur les fameux hot spot
enfin les justement ces zones où
voudrais essayer d une certaine façon de
les dissuader de poursuivre la route
d'abord il y en a des cohortes faut le
savoir dire qu'ils traversent le désert
c'est dans des camions de fortune sur
des pistes absolument abandonné enfin
pour en plus éviter de se faire tuer par
les malfaiteurs qui sont là bref etc
il est quand vous l'a demandé mais
pourquoi vous prenez la route vers
l'europe
ils ont compris ils vous disent je viens
d'une zone boko haram et là vous
établissez quoi ils sont migrants
économiques parce qu'ils viennent
chercher du travail en france ou en fait
ils sont réfugiés parce que persécutés
dans une zone ils vieilliront pas fou
non plus donc c'est assez difficile
parfois la d'établir la frontière entre
le réfugié politique et leur économie
locale ans parce qu'en fait védrine à un
plan qu'il a plusieurs fois exposé il ya
aussi des accords bilatéraux avec les
pays où les pays doivent empêcher leurs
classes moyennes aussi de partir parce
que enfin c'est pour ça c'est un sujet
global extrêmement compliqué et peu de
tête il ya quand même une hypothèse
comprend jamais parce qu'on cherche
toujours des stratégies mais je voyais
emmanuel macron dimanche quand on lui
disais mais pourquoi vous intéressez
d'un coup à l'environnement alors vous
en foutiez avant et il dit parce que
j'ai rencontré des gens j'ai consulté
j'ai lu et j'ai compris peut-être que
sur ce sujet sur lequel il n'est pas du
tout présent pendant la campagne
électorale les remontées qu'il a eu et
du quai d'orsay et du ministère de
l'intérieur et des services spéciaux et
bien il s'est dit c'est c'est un enjeu
peut-être qu'un d'opinion way peut-être
on sait pas
et rés parmi nos internautes le résume
bien ce défi à la fois politique et même
géopolitique il dit les migrants c'est
chez eux qu'il faut les aider henan où
elle semble penser accueillir est
inévitable à condition d'innover en
créant des structures d'accueil du ligne
un migrant contre cinquante mille euros
à l'europe
et si jamais on donnait ses cinquante
mille euros un développement à
développement on pourrait faire beaucoup
de choses on va passer à l'économie
française beaucoup de signaux sont au
vert la reprise de la croissance semble
durable de bons chiffres qui devrait
être confirmée ce soir par l'insee le
gouvernement sera-t-il mettre à profit
cette embellie
que faire de cette bouffée d'oxygène
alors faut-il alléger la fiscalité
soutenir la demande
quand le bâtiment va tout va nous avions
ce matin en conférence de rédaction marc
landré à leurs marques
vous avez la parole avec pour commencer
cette question macro ne fait-il que
récolter les fruits du travail de
hollande
la réponse est oui c'est clair c'est net
c'est précis je l'écris demandant figaro
il en vérité
emmanuel macron à une chance
extraordinaire c'est que dans son pull
dans sa stratégie pour sa réélection
françois hollande s'est planté d'un an
c'est à dire que ce qui arrive plein
2017 il pensait que ça arriverait fin
2016 et donc lui permettrait de pouvoir
se représenter à sa propre succession
sauf que là il ya eu l'année 2014 qui a
été complètement pourri économiquement
et qu'à tout décalé d'un an
ce qui fait ce qui devait se passer en
2015 s'est produit en 2014 ce qui devait
se passer en 2016 les produits en 2015
et ce qui devait se passer maintenant là
en 2017 c'est à dire avec 3 une
croissance qui est supérieur à 2% en
tendance annuelle avec prêtre 300000
emplois créés en glissement annuel avec
un taux de chômage qui est en baisse ce
à cette situation économique la devait
se produire fin 2016 et fin 2016
la station a pas été du tout la même
politiquement pour françois hollande
auréolé de ce bilan la contrairement à
celui qu'il avait apporté ce sac à dos
et plein de pierres dans le dos il ya un
an
ils l'ont qui lui aurait permis de se
présenter donc oui aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron bénéficie d'un d'un souffle
d'erding blast économiques eux engendré
par son prédécesseur et également grâce
à une croissance mondiale qui est
reparti en croissance et atik qui se
tient bien mais sur les fondamentaux
économiques nationaux c'est le pacte de
responsabilité
c'est le pacte 500000 formation pour les
chômeurs qui produit même faiblement ses
effets donc tout ça fait que aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron bénéficient des fruits
récolte les fruits de son prédécesseur
vous fait sourire beaucoup la question
la question du jour du figaro est celle
que vous pose c'est trouvez-vous que
l'économie française va mieux et pour le
moment vous êtes 63% donc deux tiers à
dire que non adélaïde les français
restent suspect sceptiques
effectivement les français quand même on
sent qu'il ya une amélioration de leur
moral est haut niveau qui est qui
rayonne aussi au niveau européen l
eurobaromètre qui est sorti aujourd'hui
qui montre que tous les indicateurs sont
en amélioration en termes de morale
perspective capacité à se projeter et on
commence à le sentir aussi en france et
je pense qu'on va du coup le ressentir
une fois que les données de notamment
l'insee seront seront rendus publics on
va le ressentir à ses fins assez
largement puisque on voit que déjà le
gouvernement emmanuel macron arrivé à
surfer sur un contexte qui n'était pas
encore un contexte de résultats positifs
ça va venir alimenter alimentation
moulin là parce que je sois assez
exceptionnel c'était justement la
capacité qu'avait emmanuel macron à
suspendre en quelque sorte l'impatience
des français par rapport au résultat on
a une peau temps d'un petit peu
l'évolution de la popularité depuis le
depuis son élection on a eu un état de
grâce relativement court qui a duré
jusqu'à l'été un trou d'amis un gros
trou d'air comme si les français avaient
tout à coup une espèce d'impatience très
forte par rapport à justement c'est ce
besoin cette envie de résultats et puis
en fait là il a réussi à l'inversé non
pas en monteront des résultats montrant
la preuve d'une action qui laissent
anticiper des résultats à venir
donc ça plus effectivement des résultats
réels même s'ils sont imputés à son
prédécesseur
je pense qu'il va pouvoir en tout cas se
refait longtemps sur fait dessus encore
un moment qui vous êtes d'accord pour
sur cet élan consensuel d'optimiser chou
est le triste sire nom de nous emballons
pas trop vite il ya quand même un
certain émotion le rythme indicateurs
qui sont pas si bons que ça il faut
faire attention il ya marc landré plus
spécialistes que moi mais il ya dans le
secteur industriel à mme terrisse de
surchauffe c'était hier qu est-ce qui
vont suivre au niveau de l'offre c'est
pas garantie parce qu'il ya eu un
déficit d'investissement auparavant et
donc il ya un certain nombre de secteurs
on se pose des questions
2 il ya quand même on garde quand même
un gala nombre je vise cet après-midi un
nombre de d'emploi non pourvues qui est
quand même important
mais bon c'est mon travail c'est de
faire de chaudronnier de 50 ha et puis
quand même il ya last but not least le
sujet c'est à dire le chômage enfin je
veux dire on a en tendant ciel
stabilisation on n'a pas de baisse
à ce jour il n'y a pas de baisse donc
c'est quand même sur ce sujet là que les
français attendent de voir comment on va
dire qu'elle peut être ben et son
batteur du chômage il ya une neige
non il ya une baisse sauf qu elle ne se
traduit pas encore dans le quotidien des
français
mais quand vous passez on a un climat de
tout cela il ya le froid il a ressorti
du froid on appelle un point de taux de
chômage de moins qu'au plus haut en 2015
lire ce point c'est ca les trois cent
mille personnes vers c'est parce que
c'est pas rien leur après effectivement
tout n'est pas rose non pas danser la
carioca sur la table en disant qu'il
doubla groupe de 18 la carioca fil des
nues
jean cravate du rige prochain a dit que
je pourrais danser la carioca
effectivement non on va pas sabler le
champagne
on ne s'est pas non plus youpi
youplaboum le c'est génial là la fin est
derrière nous non
en revanche il faut pouvoir être
objectif et noter que ça va mieux après
c'est vrai il reste des problèmes et
notamment apprennent que vous n'avez pas
cité qui pour moi est le plus
fondamental c'est celui du commerce
extérieur parce qu'on voit bien que la
différence entre la france et beaucoup
d'autres pays à commencer par
l'allemagne
c'est que lorsque ça va mieux
lorsqu'elle la reprise le commerce
extérieur français se dégrade
pourquoi parce que quand on a un petit
peu d'argent que font les français
il importe alors que dans les pays
étrangers il importe pas ils achètent
ils consomment nationale et donc nous on
a une balance commerciale qui se dégrade
quand ça va mieux et c'est un vrai
problème parce qu on en est quand même
maintenant à 70 milliards par an de
déficit commercial
quand les allemands font 250 milliards
d'excédents et ça y'a un moment à
l'autre enfin comblé cette démonstration
les trêves rythmes et chants allemands y
a pas accès même s'il ya des millions de
téléspectateurs
je sais pas moi que keynes que les
indicateurs ont comme influence sur les
gens et l'opinion publique
tout ce que je pense quand même c'est
que macron à une tête de ça va mieux
quand hollande dit ça va mieux les gens
croient pas pour le moment qu'en macron
dit ça va mieux pour la cei ne le dit
pas les gens on a autour de lui le
disent à leur place il a même si la
caisse et dans deux ans il a il se fixe
aussi la camry physiquement la réforme
c'est comme gp a gardé physiquement
l'impôt c'est comme ça donc après on
verra on verra si cette de sa vague
voilà on verra si ça fonctionne mais moi
ce qui me frappe dans l'exercice du
pouvoir et je pense que c'est ça qui
fait aussi qui remonte c'est qu'il a
trouvé vraiment
la distance suffisante justement avec le
pouvoir nous deux précédents présidents
de la république donnait l'impression
d'être des jouisseurs il n'arrivait pas
à dissimuler le fait qu'ils jouissaient
du fait d'être là où il était hélas lui
donne l'impression d'être concentré sur
ces dossiers alors peut-être qui c'est
un magnifique comédien peut-être que
c'est réel et donc les gens disent on
verra alors après peut-être que dans 18
mois ou dans deux ans il y aura une
lassitude s'il ne voit pas dans leur vie
quotidienne que les indicateurs qu'on
leur on s'applique à lui même ce qu'il a
dit ce ministre
ils sont pas là pour être assis dans
leurs fauteuils la situation oui il ya
vraiment un rapport au pouvoir une forme
de liturgie du pouvoir qui était
restaurée avec lui et qui pour le moment
fait que les phrases qui reviennent dans
le langage courant s'est il nous fait
pas honte on a l'impression qu'il fait
son travail donnons lui sa chance
chose que l'on n'entendait pas notamment
sur kaka de françois arthur j la façade
du tout à fait d'accord après il ya un
ensemble de réformes qui sur le fond on
va avoir de l'importance est en lien
direct avec la situation économique que
kfw que va-t-il oser faire que va-t-il
faire sur l'assurance chômage les
retraites les retraites
l'apprentissage il ya là des sujets qui
ont un lien direct avec la santé
économique du pays donc sur le fond là
et on parie t la sarthe est absolument
mais ce sont des réformes dont on verra
les effets pas avant au minimum 2019
donc effectivement sa tête de monsieur
ça va mieux
la foire qui la gardent un bon moment
parce que c'est pas le syndrome matteo
renzi c'est à dire que pendant un an ou
pendant 18 mois l'europe entière la
regarder avec admiration et puis au bout
d'un moment les gens se sont lassés et
ses retombées très vite
un dernier point les y avait les
chiffres sur la fonction publique qui
sont tombés hier
oui 2016 avec une hausse de 20 milles
objectif fonction publique tout compris
un état territoriale et hospitalière et
compris comprennent contrats aidés voilà
là aussi est une forme de timidité entre
les objectifs affichés de réduction de
la fonction publique et qui est effectif
ou alors emmanuel macron dans sa
campagne a promis de réduire le nombre
de postes d'agents publics de 120 milles
sur l'ensemble du quinquennat il
commence donc sauvé trois fonctions
publiques comme vous l'avez rappelé et
il commence par dans le budget 2010 8
qui va être votée jeudi définitivement
voté jeudi par supprimer 1600 postes
dans la seule fonction publique d'état
donc on part d'une promesse de 120
milles sur cinq ans et on commence par
1600 uniquement dans la moitié vont
grosso modo la moitié de la fonction
publique c'est peu c'est vrai que c'est
peu et on peut se dire qu'il va falloir
qu'ils qui cravache à la fin pour
rattraper son retard parce que l'on peut
pas dire qu'il prend de l'avancé sur
d'un autre côté il a soit disant une
méthodologie différente et dit moi je
veux pas faire comme mes prédécesseurs
je vais pas faire de manière comptable
en dix ans un sur deux est là ou alors
vous obliger à tailler dans vos
effectifs je vais passer un contrat avec
vous notamment avec le livre là une
collectivité locale qui on est et qu'on
était plutôt efficiente plutôt bonne
élève depuis deux ans parce qu'on leur a
tellement celle qui que bout d'un moment
il a fallu qu'elle qu'elle fasse
attention donc l on arrêter d'embaucher
sauf que maintenant il dit moi je vais
passer un contrat avec vous en tout cas
avec les 300 plus grandes
319 plus grande connectivité entre vous
pour vous fassiez des économies et comme
vous vous serez obligés de faire des
économies vous recruterez - c'est un
pari on va voir si ça marche on et la
coercition a marché c'était la baisse
des dotations
on va voir si le côté contacté un
contractuel marchera aussi bien voire
mieux
alors il ya effectivement un secteurs
dans lesquels les réductions sont pas
vraiment envisagé on va écouter agnès
buzyn la mise de la santé elle parle des
hôpitaux on écoute sur le divan les
effectifs et la surcharge de travail
dans les hôpitaux la masse salariale
augmente alors que l'activité des
hôpitaux baisse donc un effet ciseau qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui nos hôpitaux sont
dans le rouge
pour autant je pense qu'on ne peut pas
baisser les effectifs de soignants
aujourd'hui les équipes soignantes sont
sous d'énormes tensions elles font un
métier très difficile
et on ne peut pas aujourd'hui imposées
aux soignants dans les hôpitaux un
rythme encore plus élevé juste un mot
sur ce point marque à la maison c'est
toujours la critique qui est fait pour
ce qu on dit qu'on veut baisser le
nombre d'agents publics c'est vous à les
couper ou vous allez enlever des
instituteurs vous allez enlever des
infirmières etc
sauf qu'il ya 5 7 millions d'agents
publics en france hôpital états et les
collectivités locales
est ce qu'on a besoin d'avoir des
fonctionnaires qui sont jardinier
franchement dans notre pays en 2018 est
ce qu'on a besoin d'avoir des
fonctionnaires qui sont informaticiens
dans les ministères non on peut avoir
des gens qui sont contractuels on peut
avoir des gens qui sont tous du droit
privé sans forcément avoir le statut
très accommodant de fonctionnaires donc
il ya la capacité de réduire le nombre
de fonctionnaires sans statutairement
sans avoir une dégradation du service
qui est rendu au public
voilà donc la réponse est non la réponse
est non
julien sur le thème plus général de
l'embellie
le gouvernement semble vouloir en
profiter mais doit aller plus loin en
réduisant ses dépenses publiques et
alléger encore plus les charges sur les
entreprises et les salaires je vous
propose de passer à notre troisième
thème c'est l'autriche l'autriche où le
nouveau chancelier est aujourd'hui à
bruxelles son objectif rassurer les
européens sur ses intentions
et ce au lendemain de la composition de
son gouvernement et de l'arrivée en
force du fpr le parti d'extrême droite
trois ministres régaliens un un poste de
vice-chancelier
du jamais vu pour un parti d'extrême
droite européens depuis la guerre et pas
beaucoup de réactions al'inverse de ce
qui s'était passé lorsque jorg haider
était entré au gouvernement en 2000
alors voici ce qu'en disait ce matin
nathalie l'oiseau ministre des affaires
européennes qui était interrogé sur
france info sur ce point on l'a tassé le
dire avant même que le gouvernement ait
commencé réagir ça n'est pas ce qu'on
lit dans le contrat de coalition en
autriche comme en allemagne comme en
face à tant de pays il ya un contrat de
coalition entre les parties qui se
rassemblent pour gouverner ensemble
parce que 200 pages se quantifier 180 et
quelques pages ça n'est pas ce qu'on y
lit ceci étant il faut être extrêmement
vigilant
nathalie et oiseaux qui réagissait en
fait un tweet de françois hollande
lequel tweet disait la composition du
double argument du nouveau gouvernement
autrichien avec l'extrême droite dans
des ministères régaliens et contraire
aux valeurs que l'europe porte jean marc
four est la raison nathalie l'oiseau
quand elle dit faut attendre et juger
sur pièce je ferme je vais je vais vous
répondre de façon détournée en répondant
aux
question vous avez posée au début de
l'émission cette année à vous disiez
faut-il avoir peur ou faut-il banaliser
le de mémoire ni l'un ni l'autre
il faut pas probablement pas avoir peur
parce que la peur est mauvaise
conseillère et que donc là je réponds
donc à votre question de tout de suite
il faut évidemment regarder ce qui se
passe et où effectivement quelles sont
les décisions prises par cette coalition
et en même temps on ne peut pas
banaliser ça ça n'est pas de mon point
de vue ça n'est pas possible on peut pas
juste dire en bon ou non on peut pas
dire ah ben oui c'est quand même un
parti d'extrême droite avec à sa rampe
de monde membres qui ont une les propos
clairement antisémite qui tiennent en
autriche en autriche au coeur de
l'europe
j'ai pas besoin de vous faire une son
histoire les ministères de l'intérieur
de la défense et des affaires étrangères
est-ce qu'on peut regarder sa dinde en
eau du rove attendons juge bon on verra
bien non il faut être très vigilant
la centrale riz moi je suis pas
spécialisé le public autrichien
mais ce que ce que l'on découvre quand
on se plonge dans cette histoire c'est
que je sais pas s'il faut le banaliser
ici mais là bas ils sont banalisés c'est
à dire que le fpr à gouverner avec les
sociaux démocrates dans les années 80 il
ya eu la carinthie et donc nous on a nos
analogie avec le front national et s'il
y avait 3 3 membres du front national
qui avait des ministères régaliens la
france entière serait vent debout
chez eux c'est une pratique qui choque
peut-être - coco coteaux en europe
ensuite l'analogie historique je la vois
mais moi je me méfie
de la référence perpétuelle aux années
30 parce que je pense que les situations
sont pas les mêmes les risques ne sont
pas les mêmes et périls ne sont pas les
mêmes enfin ce que révèle cette
coalition et cette élection en autriche
c'est la fracture entre l'europe de
l'est et l'europe de l'ouest qui se
fondent et l'on revient au sujet
précédent sur la crise des migrants avec
toute une partie de l'europe de l'est
qui dit votre modèle multiculturel
on n'en veut pas sur ce point marc
andrey est-ce que l'autriche finalement
on peut considérer que les faits eux
acquis une culture de gouvernement et
qu'il est légitime qui soit aux manettes
appartement
le parti est autorisé à se présenter aux
élections mais il désire on le considère
comme étant lui autoriser à gouverner à
dire sinon soit on interdit un parti
c'est le cas en france mais que front
national parce qu'on estime qu'il est
sous anti sémite soin anti démocratique
et dans ce cas là on ne lui accorde pas
le droit de représenter les français est
de gouverner
soit on estime que oui dans ce cas là il
faut pas se plaindre si jamais les gens
votent pour lui fins et c'est emmanuel
macron qui dit le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes ou alors je sais
pas moi qui va aller critiquer la
manière dont la démocratie se passe dans
tel ou tel pays
faisons pareil alors est ce qui fait que
tu d'accord après jean-marc oui il faut
être extrêmement vigilant mais comment
ça elle dit enfin dire jeu il faut être
très vigilant sait faire a priori un
procès d'intention à ce qu'ils seraient
capables de faire c'est tout le problème
le sujet porte sur le fait qu'ils
contrôlent les ministères régaliens mais
c'est ça le jeu intérieur
marc-andré vous devez avoir un double en
la personne d'hugo ou alors des doublés
vous êtes en même temps ici et sur
internet que vous nous dit les soi
disant démocrate n'accepte pas les
résultats démocratiques quand ils sont
en faveur des extrêmes mais en tout cas
il
il rejoint un peu votre point de vue
adélaïde finalement l'autriche c'est un
petit pays quand même un peu ce que ça
explique pas beaucoup de réactions à 7
gouvernement et cette alliance droite
extrême beaucoup de réactions de
l'opinion publique de l'opinion de
l'état parlera ensuite des dirigeants et
de mes de l'opinion il semble pas que ça
allait susciter
je pense aussi que c'est effectivement
c'est un pays qui est pas forcément un
pays qui les concernent contrat comme le
rappelait jean marc est présente mais
globalement les français sont moins
sont moins enclins s'intéresser aux
questions politiques internationales
c'est quand même pas leur sujet de
prédilection mais pour poursuivre en
revanche analogie sûr avec le front
national 20 ans très malade disait si on
avait la même chose en france on aura eu
toute la france qui serait vent debout
je ne suis pas certaine caution si on
reprend l'histoire récente parce qu'un
événement police oui mais j'ai eu il ya
eu 21 avril 2002 où là on a eu toute la
france toute la france une bonne partie
de la france dans la rue avec des
slogans
voilà des slogans et en fait on est
quinze ans après marine le pen au second
tour élection présidentielle dans la
psychologie collective ya une
dissociation entre front national et
gouvernement
les jouets l'instant d'ailleurs on l'a
vu en scène autour de la proue est
réellement il ya quinze ans il jouit non
corrigée dans les 15 ans qui viennent et
ils sont ils sont ils sont éloignés de
l'idée de pouvoir gouverner de façon et
pour l'instant sauf qu'à chaque étape à
chaque élection on voit qu'ils grattent
il des voix qui grappille un pote là où
il s'est arrêté avant ils ont
aujourd'hui ils ont même député cdh ya
lieu de deux oui mise en vente dans les
années 80 un mode de scrutin n'est pas
le projet intégral donc là pour le coup
on va comparer mais je dire à chaque
fois ils franchissent une étape alors
effectivement inscrit un plafond de
verre qui ne pourront pas dépasser à
titre individuel aux pronostics
peut-être mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que ans apparemment en autriche et
comme si ce qui est l'équivalent nous
front national y avait des gens dont les
gouvernements dans les régions dans les
vice-présidences depuis 20 ans donc les
les esprits autrichiens sont habitués à
au fait qu'il y ait des coalitions qui à
l'extérieur de l'autriche et notamment
en france nous apparaissent comme des
événements nouveaux tours je crois pas
que ce soit nous alors parmi les
premières mesures ou décisions annoncées
il ya eu cette idée de donner un
passeport italien aux germanophones un
passeport autrichien ou italien
germanophone
ça fait quand même un peu réagir parce
qu'effectivement ils se disent très
européen mais en même temps prennent une
décision qui n'est pas pour plaire aux
italiens c'est il faut le noter
vincent c'est vous dites c'est un
passeport pardon oui ça fait beaucoup
réagir en italie le
on dit qu il était prêt à donner un
passeport autrichien à la minorité
germanophone qui dans le loot adige donc
en italie cet espace ça risque donc ça
fait 1 ça fait réagir oui c'est sûr
appréhension côté en se présentant à
bruxelles comme les européens convaincus
et mais le problème c'est qu'il ya deux
europes vraiment et on l'a vu avec la
pologne on l'a vu avec la hongrie c'est
que ces deux europes invoque de part et
d'autre les valeurs de l'europe en ne
mettant pas la même chose dans les
valeurs de l'europe et donc il ya un
dialogue de sourds et qui va être
renforcée par la victoire de crous et
son gouvernement parce que là maintenant
il ya un arc qui fait qu'ils peuvent
arriver sur pas mal de sujets en force
devant l'europe de l'ouest et
particulièrement on va reprendre une
autre référence historique autriche
hongrie là pour le coup parce que moyen
viktor orban d'un côté et puis il ya
quand même une alliance de droite
extrême droite juste de l'autre côté de
la frontière à vienne c'est tout ça est
à côté enfin je sais sert plus et des
distances très courte enfin je veux dire
on est on est sûr et qui est une porte
d'entrée très clair pour les migrants il
avait beaucoup parlent enfin c'est une
des grosses porte d'entrée donc
évidemment chelios est un sujet encore
plus important qu ici est-ce qu'il va y
avoir une alliance entre entre hongrie
et autriche ensemble cher il faut
surveiller ça parce que celle là et
c'est une possibilité oui effectivement
et au niveau des libertés publiques on
va pas faire un chapitre entier soit
libertés publiques en hongrie ici
maintenant mais c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation pour les européennes pour
résumer vous trouvez qu'il ya eu un
manque de réaction de la part des
dirigeants européens à son goût c'est la
seule réaction flagrant d'une
institution internationale
c'est le congrès juif mondial qui dit
qui dit quand même être très inquiet ce
sont ces mots très inquiet voilà alors
l'europe elle est officiellement elle
apparaît j parce qu'elle dit la dernière
fois aux mendiants kaiser ça n'a servi à
rien on a réagi on a fait beaucoup de
ces grands gestes et puis ça n'a conduit
nulle part en fait donc autant pas
réagir c'est quand même un peu
léthargique
à mon avis la réaction était plus forte
quand l'afd a fait sa poussée électorale
paradoxalement alors que c'était elle
n'avait pas de possibilité mais le
symbole était beaucoup plus fort aussi
et sans compter que la turquie nous
donner des leçons de démocratie a aussi
ses amis chers deux années sont partis
nous disent vous avez vu franchement en
europe c'est pas joli joli nous on est
plus démocrate que vous vous êtes en
tout cas 60% à me dire que vous n'avez
pas de raison d'avoir peur de ce
gouvernement de coalition droite extrême
droite en autriche
on va passer à notre quatrième thème
quatrième spécialement pour notre centre
parce qu'on va parler de votre analyse
de ce matin dans le figaro
ça concerne des réseaux sociaux 3 forcé
sur quatre n'ont pas confiance dans les
informations qu'ils trouvent sur les
réseaux sociaux
selon la sixième édition d'un baromètre
qui était publié hier par l'association
de l'économie du numérique et la poste a
contrario ces français font confiance
aux sites des médias traditionnels alors
évidemment celui du figaro et de france
inter sans aucun doute
alors fake news pseudo-informations
monté en épingle voir dénonciation
d'autant plus calomnieuse qu'elles sont
anonymes finiront-elles par tuer le net
vincent très moléculaire vous en faites
une formidable analyse effectivement ce
matin 'le figaro' twitter ça peut être
un pilori numérique comme vous voulez
oui il se trouve que l'on découvre via
une en gros un phénomène un processus
qui se répète chaque jour il ya une
cible qui dit une bêtise ou pas quelque
chose qui est considéré comme coupable
ou pas et il ya une meute numérique qui
se met en place et qui la poursuit et
qui la chasse avec un certain nombre de
pratiques et accompagne ça qui nous
viennent des pays anglo saxons qu'on
appelle le name and shame c'est à dire m
nommer la personne mais aussi alerté via
le compte twitter de son employeur son
employeur pour essayer de mettre sept
personnes en difficulté vis-à-vis de son
employeur et dans ceux de ce processus
il n'y a pas de défense il n'y a pas de
dialogue
il n'y a pas d' écoute il n'y a pas
d'étude du dossier parfois le papier qui
est mis en ligne n'est pas lue par les
personnes qui leurs tweets il ya
simplement le leader c'est 80 % des gens
qui re tweet ne lis pas ce plus tweetés
tout engagement excessif voilà et donc
c'est à c'est un révélateur il me semble
de de cette bombe à fragmentation
sociale qui se sont fait les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire que les gens
restent entre eux qu'ils ont
l'impression de s'ouvrir mais qu' il
faut un effort et une volonté pour ne
pas choisir des comptes qui correspond à
ce qu'on veut entendre ce qu'on veut
lire et donc qui je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion à mener sur cette pratique que
je fais pas comment la qualifier des
civilisés je sais pas si c'est le mot
que l'on peut voir sur ce je vous parle
de twitter je pratique - facebook qui
parfois peut être vraiment glaçante
c'est à dire que on a l'impression qu'il
n'y a plus aucune retenue
en fait voilà ce qui arrive dans la vie
commune et dans la conversation c'est à
dire une descente une retenue le fait
que l'autre est un visage qu'on fasse
attention à la wilaya plus tout ça et ça
peut être parfois effrayant bon après il
ya aussi des choses très bonne moi j'ai
un compte twitter que je vais demain
matin et voilà donc
mais je sens c'est un champ de réflexion
important et notamment pour la jeunesse
qui je crois qu aux etats-unis 30% des
jeunes ne savent cependant que par les
réseaux sociaux est d'ailleurs plus nage
ça marche at que twitter il ya un mois
j'étais j'intervenais dans une classe de
terminale pour parler du métier de
journaliste et de son évolution depuis
20 ans que je suis journaliste et de son
évolution à venir
psion si tant est qu'on puisse essayer
de le deviner
et je le redis la junte hi tech fait
parmi vous qui lit la presse ou qui
s'informent par un autre moyen 15 aux
socios personne qui est abonnée personne
n'y avait effectivement mon père est
abonnée au monde et l'auto courrier va
quoi courrier international
bon mais je dis mais comment vous
informés quasiment l'ultra majorité
simple dans sa forme et via facebook via
facebook
donc effectivement avec nous avait on
véhicule des vrais des faux informations
et tout ça s'est noyé dans un espèce de
magma compliqué dont il est compliqué
quand on a pas encore à l'esprit de
conscience de faire la part des choses
talant teint il a donné la parole tout
de suite alors que nous avoir rejoints
je suis sûr que vous avez des tonnes de
choses à nous dire là dessus et vous
dites que c'est assez partagés
finalement sur la question font peut-on
faire confiance au réseau
oui oui car maman c'est assez partagés
j'ai posé la question sur twitter nous
internautes je vais revenir un peu plus
tard on va voir ce qu'ils nous répondent
tout d'abord faut savoir que ces 83 %
des français qui sont connectés à
internet dont 87% tous les jours donc
c'est ce qu'on apprend dans un baromètre
de l'association de l'économie et du
numérique pas et la poste et pourtant
trois français sur quatre n'ont pas
confiance dans les informations qu'ils
trouvent sur les réseaux sociaux comme
nous l'indiquent notamment donc cet
internaute sur sam chat c'est un nouveau
moyen assez rapide et efficace mais qui
fait perdre de vue que l'actualité ne se
résume pas en quelques secondes ou
quelques phrases ce moyen facile rend
les gens si paresseux de lire de
chercher et d'écouter les médias
traditionnels
alors c'est vrai qu'entre les fêtes news
les buzz inutile partager des millions
de fois sur twitter piratage de comptes
fuite de données personnelles
bref les craintes sont très nombreuses
alors qu apprécie-t-il au final vraiment
sur les réseaux nous sommes une émission
interactive nous vous donnons la parole
et voici ce que vous m'avez répondu à la
question twitter on va voir les
résultats dans quelques instants
donc
la question de twitter c'était on va
peut-être l'avoir c'était en gros 50 2 %
considèrent que les réseaux sociaux sont
fiables et 48%
voilà celle ci pour les médias
traditionnels je vous le disais donc
c'est très contrastées alors voilà ce
qu'on m'a répondu à cette question
pourquoi
sofien nous dit les réseaux sociaux tout
simplement parce qu'on y trouve
également les informations des médias
traditionnels nous les premiers
effectivement le figaro on a encore
henry qui nous dit les médias rapportent
souvent ce que le maquereau nisme leur
dicte alors que les réseaux sociaux
voient le réel quotidiennement et le
transmettre sans masquer la vérité il ya
toujours cette crainte en fait et cette
manipulation de manipulation et de
moindres dépenses des médias de la part
des internautes
on a encore jane qui nous dit dans la
mesure où les médias sont très présents
sur les réseaux sociaux
l'un va avec l'autre on a aussi ana qui
nous dit les réseaux sociaux on peut
voir tous les avis de tous bords alors
que les médias selon elle ne donne que
le leur pour finir on à drieu qui
développe un peu plus il n'y a aucune
vraie pluralité dans les médias
traditionnels ils sont muselés par le
politiquement correct et ils ont tous
plus ou moins la même vision du monde
bien sûr il ya toujours des outsiders
mais qui sont évincés lorsque leurs
paroles se libèrent
voilà donc les avis des internautes sur
twitter
on terminera avec ce tweet de la poste
donc partenaire de ce baromètre que je
vous mentionnais tout à l'heure dans ce
baromètre on apprend également que 86 %
des français considèrent qu'internet
donne accès à une diversité de points de
vue cette émission je pense n'a jamais
aussi bien porté son nom
avec ce tweet des points de vue oui on
en donne via les réseaux sociaux les
vôtres eh bien merci valentin d'accord
avec ces analyses des de dix ans que les
médias traditionnels sont finalement
l'éclectique que ce qu'on peut trouver
sur les réseaux puis l'amour c'est beau
la guerre celle est donc en amont n'a
pas rangé l'eau chaude alors je voudrais
juste signaler c'est pour être pour
rendre à césar c'est charlotte darche
qui est une des chevilles ouvrières de
cette émission en coulisses qui me
signalait le site bloomberg pessimisme
'guide' un site qui étudient des
scénarios et là les scénarios pour 2028
alors parmi les scénarios étudiés il ya
la réélection de trump la guerre une
guerre déclenchée par la corée du nord
et la disparition de facebook à cause
d'effets spéciaux c'est un scénario très
sérieusement étudié ça vous fait réagir
des lignes non mais sur la confiance sur
les réseaux sociaux
c'est intéressant ce que tu as côté des
français disent clairement dans
l'enquêté vous mentionnez que les
français n'ont pas confiance et en même
temps malgré tout la conscience qui va
voir je pense qu'ils sont soumis eux
mêmes les informations qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas et nous on a travaillé
pendant la campagne justement sur la
question des tec news
on a fait un travail pour amener des
chercheuses américaine on a trait sur
des échantillons différencier mais je
vais pas vous raconter la méthode mais
la conclusion c'était que une fois qu'un
qu'une technique zèle et l arrivée dans
votre esprit
même si après vous êtes soumis un
élément si il ya toujours cette petite
musique qui reste est du coup c'est un
vrai sujet c'est un enjeu en termes de
démocratie en termes d'information et
c'est vrai que ça questionne vraiment
sur la question effectivement de
l'éducation de nos enfants la pédagogie
mais c'est un sujet qui est qui et
panneaux très juste pour finir sur le
chiffre que vous citiez sur la vita très
contrastées chez les questions twitter
on est on s'interroge à l'intérieur des
gens voilà qui sont plutôt qu'ils ont
plutôt un biais favorable au réseau un
dernier mot jean marc transcrire 13 ans
constate quand il ya un événement
important
les gens reviennent aux médias
traditionnels on le constate à peu près
dans tous les médias traditionnels il
n'y a plus d'audience télévision
radio presse écrite à tout lui revient
puis ensuite tout petit dernier mot on
peut pas mettre je pense tous les
réseaux sociaux dans le même sac et pour
venir à twitter on pourriez passer
l'émission entière et moi je crois
qu'effectivement particulièrement et
twitter il ya un double effet soufflé au
fromage c'est à dire qu'il ya des trucs
qui monte en épingle comme ça
extrêmement vie de façon place est
excessive
c'est l'autre par twitter il ya des
études américaines là dessus qu'ils le
montrent c'est une caisse de
rétrécissement de l'information sa
n'élargit pas votre champs
d'informations ça le récit parce que de
fait c'est la même chose que le souffle
au fromage il ya des sujets qui monte
qui monte qui monte mais en fait c'est
un petit nombre de sujets qui étaient
traités par haine par une petite partie
de la population donc twitter ne vous
donne pas une image très juste de du
monde environnant
ce seront les mots de la fin merci
continuer nous suivre sur le figaro
figaro live figaro.fr
thouvenot notre déploiement médiatique
merci merci à vous les des ciseaux et
yade à son six heures passées en deuil
on donne le chiffre de l'insee marque
anglaise s'en sont croissants sont
depuis très divisé la hausse de 0 2
point et bien cours et cochons ne brise
pas les embargos sur un loup garou life
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et à
demain pour un nouveau point de vue et
dans quelques instants
vous pourrez suivre un numéro de
conversations marie-laëtitia bonavita
reçoit arnaud de la grange arnaud de la
grange qui est donc rédacteurs directeur
de la rédaction du figaro et qui a écrit
les vents noir c'est paru chez grasset
cette année merci beaucoup
[Musique]